Pete did you use to watch the TV show
cops you know I watched a little bit of
it like I like I'm sure everybody's seen
a little bit of it but once you've seen
a guy like you take his shirt off and
jump a fence and run through somebody's
backyard you basically seen cops so yeah
I've seen it and it's part of the
grammar I think actually of nonfiction
storytelling it was one of the early
reality shows actually that and I think
the real world maybe and yeah of course
everybody brings up cops when you know
they hear about our project so sure but
from from the few times that you did
watch cops to now spending what is it
two and a half years with three years
almost three years okay and doing
probably ride-alongs how do you see cops
which is sort of this glorified but also
haha look at this kind of thing when
it's really you you've been on
ride-alongs you've had your life
basically on the line filming you know
one of the things that we try to
articulate when we're trying to get
access because a big part of nonfiction
filmmaking is about access and you you
can't write these stories you have to
document them and in order to document
them particularly in an institution you
got to get in there and part of you know
the pitch is to say that we're not just
gonna drop in parachute and parachute
out find the most dramatic moments and
exploit them and and sort of distort the
reality of the context in which that
really gives this place a meaning so if
you if you think about policing in
America it's not that the most dramatic
moments that are the most meaningful to
the context around those moments and the
only way that you can get to that is by
really committing to time and and doing
that long deep dive into you know what
does it mean you you know you see these
cops dealing with violence or you
domestic violence you see a cop chasing
somebody who's robbed a store or young
young
an American kid who is that kid where
does that kid come from did that kid
graduate high school you know though
that context for us is everything and so
we're cops ends we begin basically I
mean we do have there is action in the
movie it's not it's not you know it
there's quite a bit of action and it
actually but we also take a deeper dive
in trying to help you understand you
know in unpacking it's full three
dimensions these men and women who
really are being you know maligned and
criticized rightfully so and in our
society for being detached from you know
the consequences and accountability of
their actions and so I think that was
part of the sort of impetus for for
making the film in the first place so I
know it's part of a trilogy and you're
you've yet to make the third one but
what was the driving force no pun
intended but to make the force what was
the main day that you just looked at the
story of what was going on with the
Oakland Police Department I think in
2013 right yeah so there was a different
story at that time and I know things
have evolved but what was the reason
well when we first when we came off of
our first film the waiting room which
was the first in a trilogy of films
looking at the relationship between
public institutions and community in one
American city Oakland California
I was sitting for breakfast with my
executive producer John L sue also I
studied with that in film school he was
my mentor and he sort of taught me
everything I know about much of what I
know about documentary film and he was
saying hey we should take a look at you
know the police department here you know
there hadn't been a major American
documentary set inside a urban police
department probably since the the police
tapes Alan and Susan Raymond's film set
in New York I mean there been a lot of
reality shows cops and so forth the
first 48 and all these these reality
shows but a real deep dive into an
American Police Department hadn't been
made in quite some time
and it was at a moment when there were
so many questions about you know the the
the culture and the institution itself
and how it intersected with matters of
race and justice and and so this was
also a police department that was in an
active process of reform they had been
forced to reform due to civil rights
case in 2000 the rioters case which was
these cops were going out at night you
know violating people's civil rights
planning drugs you know harassing them
beating them in some cases and that
resulted in a negotiated settlement
agreement that required them to change
and so we were we picked up with them
just as they were getting ready to
complete all the requirements of reform
they were in what like the 12th yeah
when we started that they're in the 12th
year and then the chief Shan went we see
in the film he was brought in to
basically close the deal all right let's
we're almost done there's a couple more
things here one of them was racial
profiling that we need to get a handle
on and he was brought into to do that so
how did you contact the Oakland Police
Department I mean I know Donna Watson
film talks about working with you but
initially you were turned down yeah well
we weren't turned turned down per se but
we definitely didn't make the ask right
away what John you know because once you
make that ass that's it like once you
make the ask it's easy to say no you
know so what what you like to do when
you're trying to get access to
institutions I teach this to students
all the time as you you know really sort
of bill start to build support around
the periphery of that institution to
find people who you know understand what
you're trying to do who you you know our
supporters who can start telling that
narrative so when the time comes to make
that ask and those people start at
talking and you know who these guys are
you you know there's already some
foundation of support and so the wait
when the waiting-room came out it was
such a kind of came out of nowhere you
know it got shortlisted for an Academy
Award it went a spirit award
you know nominated for Gotham and
it was really kind of a pride of the
city and so the mayor brought me I was a
guest of at the State of the City
address and she that she introduced me
and said these are the type of artists
that we need to support and the US
Attorney for Northern California was
there Melinda Hague and and she had seen
the film and she was a huge supporter
and she's like what are you doing next
and I said I'd like to try to get into
the police department I'm not sure how I
would do that and so she said well let
me see if I can help you know so people
like that you know we started telling
our story like this is what we want to
do this is our intent and we were
nervous because what you weren't just
trying to get into a Police Department
it was a police department that was
under federal watch and so we were
thinking how man we got yet like like
Obama has to sign off on it like what
like how deep is this gonna go you know
and we weren't really sure so but we a
lot of it was the waiting room how well
that film did how much the community
loved that film how much they valued
what that added you know to the national
conversation around access to health
care and I think that played a pretty
significant role so when you were
planning the film I understand that you
prefer Verte style and sort of like the
talking head sort of documentaries were
you concerned for your own safety had
you ever seen anyone shot or stabbed in
your own life like at you know traveling
in the Bay Area you know I've been
around some pretty hairy situations you
know and part of my story you know was
intersecting with law enforcement when I
was in college you know I got in trouble
I got arrested and I ended up serving a
year in prison on a drug charge and so
but I didn't have the experience that a
lot of young African Americans have and
I don't know if it's because I'm a mixed
race I'm lighter skin the way I dress
the way I talk the way I carry myself
I'm not really sure but the most
memorable the first you know memorable
experience I had with law enforcement
was them basically saving my life
by intersecting me and it very sort of
where I could have gone either way you
know act where it could have gone either
way but when I was in prison I met first
day I was in prison somebody got their
throat cut you know and I was around
young black men just like me but from
the other side of the tracks and so I
had a very unique kind of coming of age
this is when I was in 21 this is you
know right at that moment where you're
starting to sort of come into your
identity and but I did grow up in
suburbs of Boston and I went to private
school and went to Howard University and
so I I've always carried with me these
diverse experiences in my storytelling
but the reality is that these cops what
I experienced is just a fraction of what
people who grow up in places like
Oakland or West Baltimore or the Bronx
experience on a day-to-day basis every
day all day surrounded by poverty
violence crime where it's just sort of
par for the course to see a friend shot
down in front of you and I was just
having a conversation with one of the
often what the cop who appears in the
film captain Armstrong and you know who
lost his brother when he was 13 you know
and so these these words and he's from
Oakland you know so these are
experiences that the average person just
doesn't have any conception of and so
when I was out with the officers I'm I'm
wearing body armor there were embodying
armor this is the environment that
you're that you're working in you know
this is their job I'm a filmmaker my job
is to document but immediately and
that's in that space I'm thrust into
their point of view in a very visceral
way because I'm feeling on some level
the same feeling that they are maybe
even elevated because I don't have a
weapon you know I have nothing to
protect myself other than them you know
so
it it really shifted you know as someone
who's aggressively open-minded and I
went into this process not wanting to
you know go after the police and try to
like you know muckrake and find bad
stuff you know in the department but I
also went in there really guarding
against getting too close to them
emotionally and being too sympathetic
with them because I understood that this
is a moment when people had a lot of
anger rightfully so and distrust toward
the police and wanted that truth to be
told about what was happening in our
Police Department and so my job as a
documentarian was to try to capture as
close as I could the truth of what was
happening in this in this environment
speaking of which we talked about being
open minded and most people from the bay
area would probably consider themselves
that way and I know there's a very
progressive mindset there but you say
people saw you get out of the police car
with the camera and somehow you were
trolled on Twitter and I was just
wondering you talked about being a
filmmaker trying to make something and
what were they saying to you well it's
difficult you know I'm trying to write
you know I try to reconcile this to
every my experience it was flipped
because because what happened was the
people who are being open and
transparent and welcoming of me with a
boob of the cops and the people that
were being aggressive and prejudiced and
and hurtful to toward me with the
progressives many of whom were my
friends so you know but my friends
understood they knew me they knew my
story and so when I see them is like an
odd sort of cognitive dissonance I'm
getting out the police car they're
they're protesting the police I think
they understood what I was trying to do
a lot of people did not even attempt to
understand what I was doing they never
spoke to me they never asked me
questions they were taking my picture
they were trying to spin a narrative on
social media but I was an agent for
propaganda for the police department and
that was incredibly frustrating from
you know and I had to constantly sort of
challenge myself to not slip into a
mindset of being resentful of that it
was you know I think there still I think
I was impacted by it in ways that law
have always changed changed me and but
one of the things that I know because I
know a lot of people in whatever you
want to call it black lives matter or
the protest movement who are fighting
for social justice and that's a value
that I hold very close to my heart
because of my personal experience where
I come from my dad went to school with
Martin Luther King I grew up in the
civil rights you know I grew up I was
born in 1968 and so but you work harder
to understand people when you know that
when you have a connection to them and I
think that's something that we've lost
in this country is the ability to
oftentimes when we're upset with each
other we're upset with people that we
don't really know who they are and I
think that's certainly the case with
with cops and the only experience a lot
of African Americans have is being
profiled by a cop or being talked down
to by a cop or being harassed by a cop
and that you just carry that with you
and so we we as filmmakers we had a
really tricky particularly as a black
filmmaker at a very tricky job which is
to somehow thread the needle and respect
that reality while also trying to hold
the truth of these officers in a
meaningful way because they they're they
see themselves much differently then the
public sees them they see themselves as
protecting black lives everyday yeah so
it's it's it's it's a really profound
you know
golf that we find ourselves in in terms
of you know where people are and how
people see each other and we were
capturing that that's what we were sort
of in the process of capturing how did
you get permission to go on these
ride-alongs because that footage is so
valuable yeah how did you get access to
that but we we just asked we definitely
like we said we want to understand what
it's like to be a cop and you know you
know a lot of what being a cop is or
just responding to the radio call you
know like and because there's so many
radio calls it's shocking that the
volume of 911 calls that this department
gets and it's only 750 officers in a
city half a million people so we
definitely wanted to get that sense that
visceral sense of you know the officers
just doing their job they're there sort
of in there's a little bit more like the
waiting room of you know - the politics
you know what's an average day like you
know what does an average day look like
to you and so no the only way you're
gonna get that is by getting inside that
that car and just and following them go
and call to call to call so we we did
quite a bit of that initially though it
was like all protests cause like we
started filming right around the time
that um you know the decision was made
not to indict there Darren Wilson in the
shooting Mike Michael Brown so that
sparked weeks of protests in Oakland and
so that's all we were filming for the
first several weeks so you talked about
some of the response from the activist
community toward you on social media I
just wanted to read something that I saw
on the force IMDB page and a woman had
reviewed the film and she said well I do
believe that Nicks allows the OPD to
display their good side he did not let
them hide their dirt either when
emotions run high it's difficult to
stand back and show both sides fairly
but I think he did just that mm-hmm you
know that was our intent and I think to
you know some people cannot it's it's
it's remarkable because the film is a
really devastating indictment of this
department and of thee so what's broken
within the institution the moral failure
that ultimately occurred at this
department and I and I told them going
and I said you know I'm gonna be fair to
you but I'm also gonna tell the story
that I see that I experienced that it
that I witness and you know humanizing
someone doesn't mean necessarily making
them look good it means revealing them
in their full three dimensions and
that's what we do like you know that's
our that's the old value proposition of
of open hood is to sort of get to that
authenticity through visceral
observational storytelling and but the
funny thing is like you know we've
screened this thing to lots of audiences
and different types of people and some
people still take issue with with still
perceived the film as a Pro cop film and
that's because the anger and the
distrust and and the the pain that
people are carrying is so deep that any
step toward showing a cop in in a
positive light is is seen as as
some some degree or some for some shade
of propaganda and you know there there
was a spectrum of sort of resistance to
to the police in this country that
ranges from sort of all lives matter
Procope people to abolitionists who
believe that we should remove all police
from our communities and replace it with
a completely new paradigm and model for
community and public safety and so I
think woven through that as some some
degree of performance that bubbles up
and and it's very difficult sometimes to
it like like in other words no
moderation it's it's whose side are you
on
define your values articulate those
values without compromise and I think
when you know you have a balance to fit
a fair and balanced approach that is
perceived as a compromise by by many and
so we've had to we've had to respond to
that and that has come out in in some of
the reviews of the film not many many of
the reviews reflect the comment that
you've just read there but there have
been some that have been more critical
of the balanced approach like this
doesn't require a balanced approach this
requires incisive you know an incisive
take down and so that's something that
it's just a reality it's just a reality
right now and our sort of public
consciousness around this issue I think
the beginning of the film is much
different from the middle of the film
and toward the end when for me I was ya
felt like a punch in the gut so I saw it
going one way and I was drawn in but I
for me
and this is just my experience yeah
didn't didn't see it in that way knowing
that you started out with one intention
for the film and then things changed and
without I guess giving away too much how
was that because it was a drastic turn
of events
well narrative Lee was an incredibly
challenging film to put together in the
Edit in the Edit room and we had many
many meetings in our model is an
interesting sort of model like I'm the
director I also shoot and then I have a
producer Linda Davis and then I have my
editor also does sound so Lawrence the
room is there and he's also a producer
and so that's our team primarily and
then john else who is the executive
producer he also did some shooting and
and john's asur legendary a documentary
photographer and director and and then
we had Sean he was our associate
producer he's kind of a
jack-of-all-trades it's kind of fix her
problem solver so it's a very small team
and we made the film sort of like we
shot the film consecutive with editing
the film so we were shooting which you
we had a day down shooting we'd start
putting stuff together and as we went
everything was starting to change in the
country black lives matter was emerging
it was becoming much more difficult for
us to imagine a film coming out that was
sympathetic toward the police not that
that was our intent but what we were
observing early on was a lot of success
at that department a lot of the reforms
were working they were making progress
it was a the department was a model for
reform and in our minds we were thinking
well how was this film gonna sit and
when at the same time this is what we're
seeing we're seeing all these incidences
on our Facebook feeds Eric Gardner and
and and Tamir rice
you know Mike Brown like all these
things were happening one after the
other after the other and it we were
really worried actually like like that
we were gonna appear to be tone-deaf
and so we constantly were asking
ourselves what are we doing how we
framing the story
there's a lot we cut a lot of versions
of this film at one point I tried
narrating the film myself from the
perspective of a black person who's
trying to make a film that impacts the
african-american community and and in
that in the end we decided on the
approach that we did which was a two
year up you know window into a
department attempting to reform at this
moment in time which was a seminal
moment in the in the history of policing
but also on probably the most dramatic
moment in the history of the OPD like no
question about that and and the film as
a result of that framing you know this
is a two-year journey and it involves
lots of twists and turns
the last which is particularly dramatic
and did feel like I'd punched in the gut
to us as well because it just came out
of it came out of nowhere it came out of
nowhere and so that's how we that's how
we rendered it in the film it's a sharp
turn in the film and but that's exactly
how how we experienced it I thought it
was effective to how you had the
headlines of these various publications
about the different turns and I thought
that was just a way to sort of just let
it be and and show it without any I mean
these were real headlines that I just
thought I was very effective yeah we
really mean that we made that choice
because we didn't want to try to
interpret and editorialize what was
happening but there was a whole group of
journalists and investigative reporters
who were tracking this thing and trying
to make sense of it and so that that was
how the public was experiencing it
that's how we were experiencing it and
we wanted to sort of allow it also
allowed us to add a little bit of
context to to the material to sort of
ground the audience a little bit better
how long was the typical filming day and
what were you choosing to film and what
were you choosing tenets to leave out it
it changed like in the beginning was
protests protests protests you know some
some days were out there twelve fourteen
depent depend depend on you know who we
were following we were kind of casting
in the beginning trying to find officers
who we would follow you know for the for
the whole film one of the original
central questions of the film was who
becomes a cop and why and how does the
job change you so we were you know just
hanging out with lots of different
people but you know the the doctors
I mean cops like doctors it never stops
right so they they they tend to go on
like 12 12 hour shifts and so that was
fairly typical that we just be out and a
lot you know some nights were just like
slow and boring and another other nights
were just like bang bang bang bang bang
were like 12 you go by and you'd be like
you'd have hours of footage in the
camera you couldn't believe it that that
that amount of time it had a lapse and
that was more the rule than the
exception and we were in lots of
different environments from you know
doing ride-alongs we did I mean those
painful thing were the City Council
hearings is we were just like and I was
like I'm like I'm at grew up in the
black church so I'm used to like you
know but it's like people testifying
getting up there like long lines of
community voicing their concerns about
the issues and we would tend to go to
these City Council meetings when they
were when an issue a policing issue was
on the docket we go to see where where
does the community at on this and and
how how are they how was the chief gonna
respond or how is the mayor going to
respond and we were trying to like build
this this this sort of an environment of
and a lot of that material ended up not
making it into the film when everything
changed then the young way to recut the
whole film but we film tons of that
stuff boring is how like and then we
also a lot of press conferences but
these are the pieces that you have to
you have to gather you know all the
pieces to ultimately to sort of have
options because they're all building
blocks for the story we've seen some
behind the scenes footage of you filming
with quite a large camera what were you
using or did it vary from time to time
we were using a sony f5 which is
it's a bit of a cinema camera a lot of
like indie filmmakers doing narrative
features we use that it's it's better
for like setups where you're putting the
camera like on a tripod or you know on a
Steadicam or a dolly or something but
it's a really good camera in low-light
and we knew we were gonna be doing a lot
of shooting at night and so we tested a
lot of cameras and that would perform
the best at least in my opinion and I
shoot my own film so I'm very kind of
particular about about that and then we
shot on a sony alpha 7s which is a small
DSLR camera for all the interior car
stuff POV stuff so we had suction mounts
so that you could really sort of be
there in the car with these officers as
they're speeding through the streets we
wanted to give the audience kind of a
visceral feeling of that and that camera
is also extremely good in low light so
that was those were just kind of a
coincidence they were there both Sony
cameras we should have gotten some money
from Sonia on the film but um you know I
thought the film actually looked great
and you know I'm a cinematographer so I
was kind of going for I wanted the film
to you know just be immersive and
beautiful I mean that that was part of
part of my goal and it's very difficult
to do when you're on the fly when you're
also trying to capture reality right you
can't because you can't stop you have to
sort of like kind of have it pre-planned
and serendipity plays a role in that you
have to get lucky sometimes all right so
did you use any lighting equipment no no
wow never yeah I don't use lights and
any of my work I use natural light I
look for opportunities to introduce
light into into the scene like one of
the tricks that we used in the interiors
was the cops have this like laptop that
they use for all like to track all their
calls and so we would use that as a
little fill sometimes we'd open it up
and that would cast a little soft glow
inside the
like all practical lighting sometimes
we'd use the dome light the overhead but
we didn't bring in any of our own lights
because you just can't you can't manage
that when you're particularly when
you're running a documentary anyway it's
hard to do that but when you're running
around with cops sometimes you know
you're wearing a bulletproof vest you're
in a very hairy situation so you have to
pick up and go sometimes and so you
can't be having you know equipment and
stuff like that so yeah that's how we
did it so last question Pete coming off
the success of your documentary the
waiting room how did you want to build
on that with the force yeah so you know
with the waiting room well what one of
the things I was exciting about the
waiting room was was creating this
immersive experience for people like you
know trying to really immerse them in a
world without you know in Verte which
had a little bit of voiceover that that
we used in the film and with with with
but it was confined you know for the
most part to this hospital waiting room
I mean everything was like in close-up
it was very almost like like like like
um you know intimate and confined in
this interior space whereas with with
the police movie I felt like man we can
break out and we can see the city get
more visual and as a cinematographer
that's just incredibly exciting to be
able to sort of break out of that
claustrophobic kind of feeling even
though it was really effective you know
for the waiting room that claustrophobic
feeling because that's what it feels
like to be in a hospital and feeling it
in a waiting room
this film gave me the opportunity to
really kind of stretch out and sort of
you know get visual with the film and
that that for me is something that you
know excites me and also we made the
decision that we were not gonna have any
voice over that was gonna be pure
you know cinema verite and we had a
little bit of text cards in the
beginning just to contextualize in the
news articles but everything else was
direct cinema and you know for me for my
money that creates the most visceral
experience that that in my mind really
gets you closer to a truth even though
that may result in some ambiguity
it it creates that feeling of closeness
and authenticity that I think gives the
audience a thrill you know when there's
action and when there's emotion it just
draws the emotion out deeper than then I
mean there are different styles that are
appropriate for different subject
matters for from my films that immersion
that close is that the authenticity is
really key to the story
you